all right Lara is in Springfield
Missouri hey Laura what's up hey Dave
I'm in Springdale Arkansas Oh I goofed
up because Kelly goofed up how can I
help me I'm extremely nervous so I
apologize ahead of time but I need some
words of wisdom from you we are we just
finished FPU and we are in baby step to
going after you know gizelle intensity's
like crazy and we learned in FPU that
we're supposed to have term life 10
times my husband's annual income we were
in the process of doing that we were
going through Sanders and come to find
out my husband is uninsurable because of
his health what's wrong so he is 50
years old he's had two strokes and he's
a wartime that trend with severe PTSD
yeah I wouldn't make you one insurer pal
yeah so we're trying to figure out now
what do we do yeah yeah he's 50 years
old you got kids at home no okay
Morgan where's them how much mortgage
you got we have about a hundred and
fifty thousand how much other debt do
you have about eighty thousand and he
does have I'm sorry no you go ahead okay
he does have a policy through his
workplace for three times his annual
income that's great okay and he makes 50
a year no he makes ninety eight year
going to you yeah okay and you have
50,000 other debt is what you were
saying okay eighty eighty thousand
another death oh I'm so confused okay
anyway not counting your mortgage not
counting our mortgage private well that
you could pay off three times his salary
you can pay off the debt if something
happened to him
the only an easy way to get some
insurance when you're uninsurable is
just to buy a mortgage life insurance
policy I don't recommend those because
they're about five times more expensive
than traditional term but it's all you
can get okay and what that does is it
pays the mortgage off
if something happens to him it's a
gimmick policy but they will issue those
policies without medical meaning they
don't they just issue them to anybody so
even hon insurable people so I would get
mortgage life insurance that call your
mortgage company and see if they sell
mortgage life insurance I probably do
yeah we asked them and they do not I did
have one option that I was thinking
about doing and I wanted your opinion on
what if we like took a premium and paid
it basically to ourselves in a special
account and then bought a mutual fund
with that well you would do that every
month you would do that after you get
out of that okay you're just building
the wealth that's all you're doing and
that the whole idea is you know when
you're out of debt and build wealth and
the kids are growing on your need for
insurance starts to deplete if you had
zero debt and you had seven hundred
thousand dollars in an account you
wouldn't even call me because you even
need to insure him at that point so
you're working towards that by becoming
wealthy working your baby steps in
Financial Peace University but now we
don't need to do that today I'd pick up
a mortgage life insurance policy if you
can find one I think that's the best
thing to do this is the Dave Ramsey show